voilà ça va bien l'initiative a dit mme
aigner voit la force
[Musique]
bien sûr là
fort
[Musique]
pas très loin du peu de chevet traiter
la mairie les nombreux je veux dire
plein de choses dans ma carrière jamais
ses visées d'accord jamais j'aurais fait
des années que je me remette en question
sa femme et moi que tu pour donner les
sons de vie que tu fais très bien n'être
qu'une loi déjà fait ou ce parce que
déjà fait tellement vrai sculpter une
grande carrière sur nrj
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je lui même schéma c'est vrai chéri
d'ailleurs tu sais que tu peux les
appeler les acheter parce que tu dis à
ma main et kim kardashian times ont
généré tout el mehdi perruque
tu sais quand elles ont les cheveux
rasés mais ce marché est pas pareil moi
ça je crois que je l'aï tellement belle
et touchante tellement bien mais c'est
vrai ça pète est grand comme ça j'en ai
encore des raisins bio à des noms à
l'école alors je raconterai look et
pierre lebeau développe c'est quoi c'est
encore pire
je n'ai pas la voir
m
[Musique]
j'adore
en bas
j'étais en vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]